[Music]
and if somebody wants to get good at
selling
what uh
like you know there's a
go out there and you know try to sell a
thousand times it's one way to get get
better uh but if you wanted to improve
your rate of learning what books
courses
whatever what what youtube videos
uh like do you remember that like that
really clicked for me and that was like
kind of like a game-changing uh thing
for me and getting better at selling i
have relatively stronger beliefs about
the topic um so i think first off a lot
of people read books before they start
selling and i've thought a lot about it
and i don't think that's the right path
because you don't know what they're
talking about yeah like you only know
like what the concept of building
rapport is until you've not had rapport
and like oh
okay now i understand how this works but
like until you like until you
confront the reality like you can't you
can't bucket the knowledge into
something that's actionable so i'm a
proponent of doing first realizing the
deficiencies and then going to find the
information now to match the the real
life scenarios that you have encountered
um
the second part of the question is like
which books or things like made things
click
so um there's one moment that made
things click which was i said this in
the book sam which is like make people
offer so good they'd feel stupid saying
no which was the secret of selling right
it's like if you just make it so good
that they won't say no then it makes
your job a hundred times easier and so i
did work really hard on that side to
make my job easier and just as a quick
caveat to complete the loop from like 40
minutes ago
you said like what was the book or
training or whatever that
so it's my belief if you look at belford
you look at bradley you look at grant
cardone some of the big sales trainers
that are out there almost all of them
invariably have the same story which was
i started selling and was the best guy
on the team by a [__] mile and then i
tried to figure out what i was doing and
so i do think that some people
naturally based on their childhood their
upbringings their whatever or just have
a higher proclivity for selling which
yeah just a gift of gab and and empathy
yeah and i think it carries over into
how you recruit for selling too because
we've built a lot of sales teams and i
actually have a very short allowing for
people to fail at sales cycle probably
much shorter than most people and it's
just because i've never had a killer
sales person who didn't do pretty well
the first week and so for me we you know
we turn through this quickly but as a
result of that the team is just killers
and they know that so i like this quote
from from grant cardone he says you know
my sales team's a dangerous place to
work and
i i love that so in terms of uh sales
stuff i think that i think people don't
know how
people are really freaked out about the
idea of selling right and so i think the
first reframe is like you're not selling
you're helping someone make a decision
that's going to help themselves and the
the the front part of that is that i do
think that the number one predictor of
good sales is conviction and so
fundamentally you have one person who
should believe in something
another person who does not believe it
yet and trust is the thing that
transfers that conviction so if
fundamentally there's the two things you
need you need trust and need conviction
most times sales people don't have 100
trust sorry 100 conviction and so
the also the idea of conviction as a
binary is false so it's not like i
believe it or i don't believe it is to
what extent do i believe it right and so
that's why like in terms of if i want to
improve a sales team i can do the drills
which we do and that's like blocking
tackling but the thing that really
juices the sales team is hearing the
testimonials of the people that they
sold last week and what they're doing
today and how their lives have changed
and so i noticed this because on my
sales teams when we were in person
whenever i did weigh out day which is
when everyone finished their challenges
and everybody was crying and so excited
i tried to stack as many sales
appointments as i could while people
were weighing out and during those days
we closed like 100 because people were
like dude how can you not think this
works it's right there and so the thing
is is like you can either trick yourself
into having the right tone or you can
train yourself and i think that it's
much easier to trick yourself into it by
just simply believing because if you
talk if you truly believe in the product
you will talk about it differently
and so in terms of an understanding of
selling if you need to have conviction
you need to have trust trust is going to
come from expertise and some level of
rapport right and so um
i think that
overarchingly
to help someone sell we just have to ask
the right questions to get someone to
come to the conclusion on their own and
so most sales conversations follow more
or less the same framework
if you know what you're doing otherwise
people are just chasing their tail and
trying to chase a prospect to an outcome
that the prospect doesn't know how like
we've had this conversation a hundred
times they have only had it once we
should be the one knowing how this
conversation is supposed to go right we
should also come in with a massive
advantage to how to have this
conversation go the way we wanted to
because we do it on [__] day right
and so you know big big front end pieces
is like
why are they there
what's the problem what have they done
so far understanding where they failed
seeing why our product is different from
the things that they failed
asking for permission to explain about
the product explaining the product not
in any way based on features but only
based on the experiences that they will
have as a result of it and using
analogies to explain those experiences
right um
and then and then having a close
at the end which
the the tick tock i think that you he
references like a no base close and i
think a lot of natural sales people do
this anyways like if i want something i
might be like hey can you do this for me
i'm like hey would you mind and they say
no they don't i don't mind right like
it's natural communication dynamics that
most people who naturally know how to
persuade people or at least influence do
that on their own this is just
retroactively looking at and saying what
did i do different like why is this
different and um
in terms of like overcoming because
people are afraid of confrontation right
that's what they're afraid of
and so i believe that you can sell
without ever having confrontation and
you can do that with what i like to call
childlike curiosity and so if someone
says
um
well my husband's not going to approve
that i'm like
why wouldn't he
like huh that's so interesting tell me
more about that
rather than like all right let's like
your husband's an [__] like that's
not going to work because in arguments
no one wins right and so like
why would he think that because because
i would think that he wants what's best
for you right
yeah he wants what's best does he know
you're struggling with this right now
well i mean yeah he knows i'm struggling
with it okay so he wants a special you
know you're struggling with it so why do
you think he would be opposed to solving
something that that you're currently
struggling with
just so i understand would he be happier
if you continue to struggle
well no it's like well great
then would you be opposed to moving
forward today and that way and hey if
you go home to your husband and you make
a joke in the light of scenario then you
close it right and so it's i think
childlike curiosity is the immediate
that you have to train because people
get defensive so that is one thing that
like
fighters talk about when they're in the
ring like in the beginning you breathe
in too much right i don't know if like
if you've been like sparring and stuff
like you breathe in you breathe too much
you hyperventilate
and so the guys who've done it enough
they slow down their breathing because
when they get things get intense they
can slow it down and so i think sales is
a lot the same way where you're like
your adrenaline kicks in start breathing
faster it's fight or flight so you gotta
be able to slow down and be like huh
that's crazy i wouldn't have thought
that okay tell me more about that and
like now you're interested and then they
don't feel like you're
combating them they feel like you
genuinely are interested and want to
help them which is what you should be
doing because you should be them dude
only if it makes sense
[Music]